today we're going to be doing something
a little bit different and it's
something that brings together
many ideas in computer science and it's
the idea of
program correctness so what we're going
to be thinking about is what does it
actually mean
for a program to be correct and then how
can we specify and verify
that in some kind of precise way so
that's what we're going to be thinking
about today
program correctness
we're going to come at this problem by
means of an example and the example that
we're going to look at as a simple
compiler
so what a compiler does in computing is
it's a program that takes a high level
language and translates it down to a low
level language
which is more easy for a machine like
this one to execute
so what i'm going to show you is a
little haskell file which i've written
but it doesn't matter if you don't know
anything about haskell because it's
really incidental to everything that
we're going to talk about today
it just allows me to do everything in
quite a concise way but actually you can
do everything in any old programming
language that you like but i'm going to
explain everything
as we go along anyway we have two data
type declarations
and we have three function declarations
or function definitions rather
and what we're going to do is we're
going to explain what these do
by means of some simple examples and
then we're going to think well what does
it actually mean for the compiler which
is embedded in this code
to actually be correct so what we're
going to start off looking at
is the source language for the compiler
and it's going to be a very simple
language it's going to be the language
of
integer values combined using an
addition operator so we're going to be
building up simple arithmetic
expressions
things like 2 plus 3 plus 4. so
here is the data type declaration for
this in haskell and it's got a few
components so we'll work through these
so we're declaring a new data type
called exper for these simple
arithmetic expressions and then the data
type has two constructors for building
expressions it's got a value constructor
which takes an integer parameter and
it's got an ad constructor
which takes two sub-expressions as
arguments so this is how we're going to
build up
our simple expressions and the really
expression trees
and you might be thinking well what does
deriving show mean here well this is a
little bit of haskell magic
and it just instructs the the system to
be able to print these things
on the screen so we can view them so not
everyone's familiar with haskell so i'm
going to give you three
little examples of values in this
expression data type and these are going
to be running examples
that we're going to be using throughout
the video today so the first one
is going to be e1 and it's just going to
be a simple
integer value so we have an integer here
one
and then we tag it with the vowel
constructor and then we've called it e1
so we don't need to type this in again
whenever we type e1 now it just stands
for
vowel of one our second example is going
to be an addition
so we're going to do add of val2
and vowel three so this is like how we
would represent two plus three
as a value in our simple expression data
type so we've got a number of components
here
we've got the value two and we've got
the value three
and then we combine them with the add
constructor so it's a little bit more
verbose than what you'd normally write
down in mathematics you'd normally
just write down two plus three but here
we're doing in a programming language so
we need to be a little bit more
verbose and we're using the two
constructors of the expression data type
so just as one final example
let's do something a bit more
sophisticated let's reuse e2
and add that onto valve four so we
defined e3 here to be
the sum of e2 and the value four so what
this really is
is it's two plus three plus four and we
can use the little pretty printer here
which we got from writing deriving show
and if we print out the value of e3 what
you get is
you get the addition of two and three
here as the first parameter to the add
and then as the second parameter you
have val4 so these are three
little running examples of arithmetic
expressions
which we're going to put into our
compiler as source expressions
so the next thing we're going to think
about is what do expressions in this
language
actually mean and this is very simple in
this case expressions just
denote simple integer values so we can
think about evaluating
an expression so let's look at the three
examples so we had e1
and if we evaluated e1 we just get rid
of the vowel constructor
and we get the value one very simple if
we look at our second example which was
two plus three
if we evaluate two plus three and of
course we're just going to get five and
if we look at our third example
this is two plus three plus four bit
more verbose but when we evaluate this
one
we're going to get the value 9 as we
expect
so let's have a look at the source file
now and think how do we actually
define this evaluation function and it's
actually just a very simple
two-line recursive definition so let's
look at the two lines one by one
so the first line says if we evaluate a
value
n we simply remove the valve constructor
and we get the underlying value
n the second line says if we evaluate an
addition
of two expressions x and y all we're
going to do is evaluate the first
expression
x evaluate the second expression y that
will give us two integers and then we
can add them together
and that will be the evaluation of the
integer so it's a very
simple two-line recursive definition the
next thing we're going to look at now
is the actual compiler for these simple
arithmetic expressions
and what it's going to do is compile
from expressions down to
code and the code is going to be a
sequence of operations for a very simple
stack machine and the stack is just like
having a stack of books
it grows on strings and you always put
new values on top of the stack
so let's have some examples to see how
the compiler works first
and then we'll see how it's actually
defined in the code
if we think about our first example
value one we can compile that one
and what we're going to get is just a
sequence of a single
operation for the little machine and
what the operation is going to do
is just push that value one onto the
stack
if we look at our second example we had
add of two
and three if we compile that then we
really start to see
what the compiler is doing it's compiled
it down to a lower level sequence of
operations
and in this case what we're going to do
is we're going to do a single push of
the value 2
another push of the value 3 so that will
have two values sitting on the stack
and then you'll perform an addition on
those two values and that will leave the
value 5
sitting on top of the stack so you start
to see how the compiler here is taking
high level arithmetic expressions and
compiling them down
to lower level sequences of operations
which a machine like this one could more
easily execute
so let's have one more example let's
look at our third example two plus three
plus four if we compile this one then we
get
five operations this time we have push
of two
push of three and then add and that will
leave the value five sitting on the
stack
and then we push the value 4 and then we
perform an addition
and that will leave the value 9 sitting
on the stack at the end
so that's what the compiler does let's
have a look to see how it's actually
defined
and again it's just defined as a simple
two-line recursive
definition so if we look at the base
case for the recursion
what it's saying is if you compile a
value this is very simple
you just simply emit a single
instruction or a single operation
which pushes the value n onto the stack
whereas if you compile an addition
then you have three things to do what
you're going to do is you're going to
compile
the first part of the edition compile
the second part of the edition
and then put an add operation on at the
end and
the plus plus here is just a way in
haskell of combining lists together it's
list concatenation or list append
and this then brings us to our second
data type declaration at the top
we're defining the data type for
operations and this is very simple
there's no recursion involved this time
around
it's just simply you push an integer
value onto the stack
or you can perform an add on the top two
values on the stack
and again we're using the haskell magic
here to derive
a pretty printer which can print these
things on the screen
so that's the compiler for arithmetic
expressions
but we're not quite done yet we still
need to think about how does
code for this little stack machine
actually get executed
so again let me give you some examples
of this and then we'll see
how this is actually implemented in
terms of haskell code
so if we take some examples here so the
first example is just going to be if we
execute
the result of pushing one onto the stack
and we give it the empty stack
then you just get exactly what you
expect you get the value one sitting on
the stack remember a stack is like a
pile of books
and in this case it's a pile of integer
values and you always put things on the
top
okay so in this case we're just taking
an empty pile and then putting the value
one
on the top let's take another example
suppose we did
push 2 push 3 and then add and we
executed that with an empty stack
then we get the final stack with the
value 5 on it so the way this will
actually get executed
is the value 2 will go on the stack then
the value's three
then you'll add them together and you'll
get the value five sitting on top of the
stack and that's exactly what we get
sitting here so the very last example if
we did the two plus three plus four
example
so i do push to push three perform an
addition
push 4 perform another addition
and then hopefully we get the right
result which we do which is the value 9
sitting on the stack so this kind of
shows you how the little stack machine
actually works
so let's have a look at the code for
this so the code
looks a bit more complicated but it's
actually completely straightforward and
we can just kind of talk through this
so the way if we want to execute a push
and then we have some more code
afterwards in the context of a given
stack
is we're simply going to put that number
on top of the stack
and then continue executing the
remaining code so very simple if you
want to execute a push
you put that number on top of the stack
and then you just continue with whatever
it
was you were going to continue with the
second case says
if we're trying to execute an addition
all we're going to do
is inspect the top of the stack and hope
that we have at least two values
m and n on top of the stack and s is
everything else
and all we're going to do is add
together those two values
and then put them on top of the stack
and then we'll continue by executing
everything else that we're going to
execute so again very simple
if you perform an addition you take the
top two values of the stack
add them together and put the result
back on that's all that's going on here
and the very last case is kind of the
catch-all case it says if you've got any
other
code sequence and any old stack then
there's nothing to do
you just return the stack so this brings
us now to the issue of compiler
correctness
so what we've defined now is we've
defined a syntax for our source language
which is simple arithmetic expressions
we've defined our target language which
is a stack machine code for a simple
stack based machine
and then we had a compiler which
translates arithmetic expressions
down to the simple stack machine code
but how do we know the compiler actually
does the right thing that's the point of
this video today
we're thinking about program correctness
how do we know that our program
for compilation actually does the right
thing so that's what we're going to
think about now
so let's look at our most complicated
example
which was 2 plus 3 plus 4. so there's a
bunch of things we could do with this we
could evaluate it
and we get the result 9. very simple we
could also compile it
so we could translate it down to some
stack machine code and then we get push
push 3 add push 4 and add and then we
could execute that stack machine code
now
so what we could do is we could execute
the result of compiling
that expression using an empty stack and
what we get
is the value 9 sitting on the stack
which is exactly what we expect
and you can see here by looking at these
examples the essence of what it means
for this compiler to be correct
is that when we compile an expression
and then execute the resulting code
we get basically the same value as when
we evaluate it
so in each case we get the value nine in
the evaluation case we just get the
integer
just sitting there on its own whereas in
the compilation case
we get a stack with the value 9 sitting
on it so this is the essence of what it
means for the compiler to be correct
if we compile and then execute the code
it's the same as just evaluating the
original expression
so what we can do now is actually think
about making this precise
and kind of precisely specifying what it
means for the compiler to be correct
and then we can wrap things up by
thinking how can we actually verify that
so what i'm going to do
is write down a simple function
definition which captures
what i've just said about the compiler
being correct so i'm defining a little
function called correct
and it's going to take an arithmetic
expression e as
input and what we're going to do is
we're going to execute
the result of compiling that expression
with an empty stack
and what we want is that that's the same
as the stack we get
by just putting the value of that
expression into a stack on its own
so this generalizes what we just had
what this is saying
is if you compile an expression e and
then you execute the resulting code
using an initial stack which is empty
then what you expect to get is just the
value of the expression
sitting as a single little value on the
stack the double equal symbols here
is just haskell's operator for checking
whether two lists are actually equal
so this captures in a very precise
concise
mathematical way what it means for this
compiler to be correct but how can we
actually check
that this property is actually true well
if you were ego eyed
you might have noticed right at the top
of my file i was importing the quick
check library
and quick check is a random testing tool
which computer files already done a very
nice video on with john hughes which you
might want to check out
and what quick check does is it blasts
random test cases
through properties and it tries to check
that the property is true
for all of these test cases so we have a
property here we've got a simple
compiler correctness property
so what i can do then i can just write
quick check
the correctness property and it will run
100 test cases through it it will start
with very small things like just simple
values like 0 and 1 and 2 and so on and
then it will consider larger and larger
expressions with
more and more additions and it's trying
to find an example
which breaks this compiler correctness
property but it doesn't do it because
the compiler is correct
maybe it was a fluke maybe we can try
again let's try two or three different
runs
and in fact it doesn't matter how many
runs we do of this this is always
going to work okay because the compiler
is actually correct
so suppose we'd messed up suppose we had
a compiler which we'd implemented
incorrectly so let me break the compiler
now
let me change the compiler and this is a
very easy mistake to make
rather than compiling an addition by
compiling the first thing and then the
second thing and then omitting an ad
operation
what i'm going to do is put the add
operation in the middle and this is a
kind of very common mistake if you teach
compilers to students this is a very
common mistake that you see
in their code but it will break the
compiler correctness property
so this compiler is now incorrect let me
quick check it and it's managed to find
the counter example and in fact any
addition
will break this compiler if you work
through the details what we've seen here
now
is how in a very simple way you can
capture the correctness property
of a small but interesting program a
simple compiler
and then how you can actually verify
this or give high confidence that this
is actually doing the right thing
using an automatic testing tool such as
the quick check system
if you wanted to do this properly of
course you could do some kind of
mathematical proof
that it's also correct or that it's
correct using some kind of induction
or if you wanted some machine assistance
you could use maybe an
automated theorem prover or an automated
proof assistant
but actually for many applications just
doing this kind of high confidence
activity
of using a random testing tool like
quick check actually gives you
very strong confidence that your
programs are actually correct but
ultimately the gold standard is always
to do a proper
inductive proof or to use some kind of
proof assistant to do it for you okay so
just to summarize what we've done today
we've been looking at the problem of
program correctness
and what we've shown is how you can
prove a simple compiler correct
and the way we came at this is we first
of all defined what the source language
for the compiler was
which was simple arithmetic expressions
then we defined
what the target language was for the
compiler which is simple stack machine
code
we defined a semantics for both of those
languages we
worked out a way of evaluating
expressions and executing code
and then we had a compiler which
translated from one into the other
and then finally we formulated this
simple correctness property
and used the quick check system to check
that it was correct with high confidence
and of course if you want to do this
properly you could do a mathematical
proof
using some form of induction or you
could even use some kind of mechanized
proof assistant and maybe those would be
interesting topics for other computer
files
another day so that's it for today see
you again next time
got a cost of three blue links to black
got across one there's our routing
network that we're gonna work with
pretty simple but the routers need to
find that way
it still doesn't work so now we find
another example
where packing and unpacking failed this
is